salut à tous aujourd'hui on va regarder
quel iphone acheté en 2022 parce que
c'est compliqué il ya une gamme qui
s'intensifie qui vient plus grosses plus
large plus d'iphone du coup on peut se
demander lequel je dois prendre cette
année il ya pas moins de quatre
smartphones qui ont été présentés un
mini anormal un pro à pro max mais il ya
également les smartphones d'avant dans
les smartphones 2 2020 2019 2018 2017
bref quel iphone acheté en 2022 c'est ce
qu'on ait tout de suite
[Musique]
alors gardez pour vous simplifier
l'histoire j'ai fait ça alors ça c'est
une liste des iphone très simple très
lisible ça va nous servir pourquoi parce
que dans un monde idéal si la question
de l'argent ne se posait pas eh bien on
prendrait ce qu'elle mieux on peut
différencier bien évidemment les tailles
d'iphone le grand le petit le moyen mais
ce qui fait la vraie différence c'est
sûr c'est l'argent regardez revoir les
iphone de 2020 13 min 13 13 pro 13 pro
mac sont vantés tarifs ils vont de 8 109
900 9159 1250 mais voilà ils ont
continué ensuite avec les smartphones
2020 12 min 12 12 pro mac do the brave
je passe un peu l'histoire alors il faut
bien noter qu'ici ça c'est intéressant
en 2020 relève également le s ce qui
était se présenter lui à ce deuxième
génération ya eu en 2019 les iphone 11
en 2018 les iphone 10 16 17 max et 10 r
et puis bien évidemment en 2010 est le
gros changement anc l'arrivée de
l'iphone 10 le nouveau format l'encoche
mais également le 8 le 8 plus et avant
n'a en 2016 le 7 et 7 plus bon je vous
ai fais grâce de l'iphone si ce qu on va
complètement occulté bien évidemment et
vous allez voir que dans la plupart des
iphones qu'on a ici doit venir en
occulter un paquet pourquoi parce que la
notion la plus importante c'est le prix
on va commencer pas les smartphones les
plus chers les iphone 13 alors les
iphone 13 ils sont intéressants pour
quoi et bien parce qu'en fait vous avez
une grosse distinction à venir faire
entre d'un côté l'iphone 13 min et
l'iphone 13 et de l'autre côté l'iphone
13 pro et 13 promax qu'est ce qu'on va
retrouver en différence sur le 13 min et
le 13 vous allez avoir deux capteurs
photo un grand-angle un ultra grand
angle donc c'est vraiment la question
des usages qu'on vient se poser si on
s'en fout des spect vous intéresse c'est
les usages parce que les iphone ça vous
aura pas échappé probablement si vous en
cherchez à sont les smartphones très
complet qui marcheront très bien en
termes de performances en termes de
photos en terme de vidéo qui ont
d'écosystèmes qui est totalement
optimisé entre une apple watch entre un
macbook entre les tablettes les ipad et
compagnie bref tout un écosystème qui
marche vraiment bien c'est pour ça qu'on
a envie d'acheter un iphone sont
également des smartphones qui sont
puissants et sécurisé avec des mises à
jour régulières pour venir corriger les
différents bugs et faire évoluer
expérience logiciel et vous gardez en
plus qu'on appellera une valeur
résiduelle forte ça veut dire que si
vous achetez un iphone n'en sais rien
moi c'est 200 euros par exemple cette
année et biel conservera un prix au
lavis prochaines étapes à venir
s'effondrer donc on pourra toujours en
tirer quelque chose si on veut
le revendre sur le marché d'occasion ou
si on veut le faire reprendre par un
conditionneur ou par un opérateur donc
c'est un smartphone qui a de la valeur
qui est intéressant et en ont acheté un
iphone en perde pas trop d'argent c'est
ce qu'il faut savoir alors regardez ce
qu'il faut vraiment venir retenir ici
entre l'iphone 13 et 13 min est bien
c'est que vous avez deux capteurs photo
grand angle ultra grand-angle vous allez
avoir en plus sur le pro et pro max le
téléobjectif
on y est chauffée un peu plus loin dans
l'image mais pour autant la qualité des
capteurs grand-angle et ultra
grand-angle votre exactement les mêmes
sur l'ensemble de la gamme il y aura pas
de dégradation donc ici la différence
vous avez entre le 13 et le 13 min eh
bien ça va être une batterie plus petit
sur le 13 min un écran plus petit sinon
c'est exactement la même chose on a la
même puce on a la même performance et
c'est la même chose entre le pro et le
pro mac ça d'écrans plus grands une
batterie plus grande mais sinon c'est
exactement le même rendu en termes de
qualité donc la question ici c'est la
question du pognon et la question du
format parce que la question du format
de mettre également importante je sais
pas moi est ce que vous voulez vous un
petit iphone ou est ce que vous voulez à
votre iphone moi j'utilise un iphone 13
promax avec une coque monsieur grübel
oui je me la pète live et 13 promax il
est tellement grand qu'il sera pas fait
pour tout le monde moi j'aime bien mais
ça dans une poche ça dépasse un peu si
vous voulez pas un écran aussi grand
vous allez sur un iphone très ce procès
sera exactement la même chose l'année
dernière avec les iphone 12 et avec les
iphones ont donc la question du format
les extrêmement importante regardez par
exemple sur le pro max vous avez ici à
d'écran de 6,7 pousse sur le normal et
le prolé 2006 la cdu 6,1 pouces tandis
que miner cdu
5,4 pouces et en rien ce qui est
vraiment intéressant et je tiens à vous
dire tout de suite parce qu'on pourrait
se poser la question du est ce qu'un
nouvel os est il intéressant parce qu'il
est à 489 euros et c'est vraiment pas
cher on pourrait dire tiens tiens c'est
vrai qu'il est petit le s e il a un
écran ici de 4,7 pouces on se dit ok
effectivement alors là j'ai un écran de
4,7 pouces l'agent les 35 heures qu'elle
pousse donc en fait le midi on a
tendance à croire qu'il est plus grand
que le s e mais non c'est pas vrai du
tout pourquoi ce que sont les cieux vous
avez un design ancienne génération avec
les grandes bordure en haut et en bas et
a child réalité le format du xiii
milliers du 12 min sont plus petits que
le et ce avec un plus grand écran donc
la différence qui laissera les six
arrêts 100 du tarif à 489 euros et c'est
pour ça que le s 2020 est extrêmement
intéressant en plus de ça vous avez la
même puce que dans les iphone 12 autant
dire qu'ici vous allez de la performance
un taux qui est vraiment intéressant et
un petit prime en terme de compacité les
iphone aujourd'hui les plus petits sont
les 12 les 13 min donc ça il faut le
savoir dont posez vous la question du
format est ce que vous voulez un gros
iphone est ce que vous voulez un petit
iphone si vous voulez un iphone de
taille intermédiaire et bien tres tres
pro ce qui va faire la différence une
fois de plus c'est bien c'est l'argent
tout simplement je vais pouvoir me
refaire en photo avec 909 euros 1159
euros il ya quand même un gap et c'est
la même chose ici au niveau des 12 et 12
pro 809 emile 159 euros alors après il
ya une différence les iphone 12 ils
n'ont absolument rien à envier aux
iphone 13 il ya une petite évolution
intéressante entre les 12 et 13 mai pour
moi l'iphone 12 il reste extrêmement
canon il reste très performant il reste
très bon en photo il reste très bon
l'autonomie reste très efficace ils
iront parfaitement bien et surtout moins
cher si vous achetez aujourd'hui un
iphone dosettes à 809 euros versus 909
euros alors on pourra dire ok
s'emballent c'est pas énorme c'est pas
vrai que ça va c'est quand même pas mal
d'argent et là où c'est le plus
intéressant c'est le 12 min versus le 13
min 809 euros versus 689 euros ce qui
donne 12 min vraiment intéressant alors
plus petite batterie plus d autonomie ça
il faut aussi le savoir mais et ça ne
s'arrête pas là et ce qu'il fait pour
moi une des grosse différence est bien
c'est que en partant des iphone 12 jusqu
aux iphone 13 eh bien on a surtout des
iphone qui sont 5 g à la différence du
est ce qui est ressorti également en
2020 qui est lui et 4g donc à partir du
est ce jusqu'aux anciens modèles on est
uniquement en cas d' j'ai donc posé vous
vraiment la question est ce que vous
voulez un smartphone qui aura de la 5g
un smartphone qui aurait la 4g si vous
voulez de la 5g iphone 12 jusqu'à
l'iphone 13 avant c'est toute la 4g et
ça quand on achète un smartphone ou à
payer 500 600 euros voire plus si
affinités beaucoup plus si beaucoup
d'affinités on veut ce qui se fait mieux
et on veut ce qui vous amènera le plus
loin c'est évident pour moi aujourd'hui
qu'on apprend d'un iphone et de la 5g
donc ça vient disqualifié pas mal de
produits et là y'a vraiment cette césure
qui se fait ici là contre la 5g et la 4g
à vous de voir d'ailleurs dites moi ce
que vous voulez un smartphone qui puisse
avoir la 5g ou alors pas du tout il ya
une différence qui est vraiment
intéressante entre les iphone 12 les
iphone 13 et nos différences qui est
intéressante dans la gamme des iphone 12
souvenez vous on avait effectivement
cette différence de taille d'écran
différence de taille de batteries qu'on
va retrouver de la même manière entre
les iphone 12 12 et 12 pro max et 12 pro
vous avez compris sauf que autant entre
le xiii pro et le xiii promax vous
n'avez aucune différence nous apparaître
de l'écran avec de la batterie entre le
12 pro et 12 pro max vous avez quelques
petites différences au niveau de la
photo vous allez avoir un tel objectif
qui permettra d'aller plus loin avec le
12 pronax il sera meilleur en faible
luminosité avec le 12 pro vous avez un
zoom optique x 4 avec le 12 pronax d'un
zoom optique x 5 après entre nous de
vous à moi et que ça change grand chose
non c'est vraiment du point de détail
voilà il faut vraiment savoir donc on va
garder ici un message le plus important
est bien ça va être la différence de
taille d'écran oui absolument tout en
sachant qu'entre les modèles mini et
normaux et les modèles professionnels
sur les bouts des professionnels vous
avez une caméra lidar qui viendra
complètement optimiser vos photos de
nuit et qui optimisera totalement les
photos en mode portrait également la wii
bien évidemment c'est le lidar ça marche
bien alors si on bien regardez ce qu'est
un bon ok on va se dire écoute moi
monsieur brut est bien sympa mais j'ai
pas 700 euros j'ai pas 1200 euros à
mettre dans un smartphone dans un iphone
je le comprends pas fait alors bien
évidemment et c'est là que ça vient
extrêmement intéressant on ne veut pas
de 5 g ont dit non la 5g on peut avoir
l'iphone et ceux qui à 489 euros qui a
la même puce que tous les uns de 2020 et
ça c'est vachement bien c'est à dire que
là vous êtes sur la a14 bionic et là on
est sur l'aa 15 bionique autant vous
dire que là sa tartine du feu de dieu se
pose maintenant la question des iphone
antérieures les iphone 11 alors pour moi
l'iphone 11 c'est un smartphone qui
marche bien on a un très joli produit
mais pas sur l'iphone 11 à partir de
l'iphone onze pros ou 2,11 promax
regarde il va avoir un écran lcd on est
sur du hd effectivement il est moins
cher on peut encore trouver en neuf à
589 euros pourrait dire pourquoi pas
mais quitte à mettre un peu plus
d'argent et bien je vous invite à venir
monter tout de suite sur pourquoi pas un
12 min c'est beaucoup plus petit bien
évidemment on est d'accord nourris dans
tout autre chose en terme de qualité
d'écran c'est vraiment autre chose on
est sur du au lait d'ici versus du lcd
alors une fois de plus apple travaille
extrêmement bien ces dalles lcd sont
très bien maîtrisé même les écrans hd
ils sont très très bons mais par rapport
à ça pour trouver sur le marché je vous
conseillerais pas après pourquoi pas si
vous retrouver vraiment reconditionnés
je l'avais envoyé un moteur de 450 euros
mais guère plus c'est pas le spartak et
venir vous conseillez je vais davantage
vous inviter à venir sur le onze pros
qui sera un peu plus xian quand vous
trouvez en reconditionnés donc on va
venir se supprimer celui-là voyez
on supprime le 11 on peut se garder le
onze pros et on se promet qu'une fois de
plus c'est une question de taille ils
sont quasiment au même prix sur des
sites reconditionnés alors petit aparté
petit bémol petite poche le
reconditionner quelque chose d'
extrêmement intéressant j'en ai parlé
n'y a pas trente ans dans une vidéo
allez la voir si vous voulez acheter
reconditionnés n'achetez pas n'importe
où sur n'importe quel site fectivement
connaîtra aujourd'hui bac market mais
bat market n'est qu'une marketplace unr
conditionne pas donc fait vraiment
attention reconditionnés en arrière
s'est trouvé un reconditionneurs qui
marche bien je défais une vidéo sur
smart key un recompte des soigneurs qui
marche très très bien c'est pas du tout
sponsorisé par mois mais c'est vraiment
à le dire parce que allé les voir et
c'est vraiment intéressant et vous
comprendrez comment marche le
reconditionnement parce qu'il faut
derrière conditionnement soient bien
faits avec des écrans et des batteries
de bonne qualité bref un vrai bon savoir
faire maîtrisé donc allé voir la vidéo
et puisqu'on parle de vidéos et bien
justement il ya un truc qui est vraiment
intéressant puisque vous avez un iphone
il ya pensé à venir le protégé ben ouais
avec les coques de nos partenaires et
nos shield une au chili sont sympas ils
m'ont fait une coque personnalisé
monsieur roux vous pouvez pas la
trouverez les cas moi mais vous pouvez
faire vous aussi vos codes personnalisés
et si vous le souhaitez regarder voir
par ici vous avez beaucoup de produits
chers inochi que vous avez des soli de
suite vont venir couvrir totalement la
face arrière de votre iphone vous avez
des mots des knicks vous avez des
cordons vous avez du câble de tous les
côtés vous avez des protections d'écran
et si on veut vraiment des
collaborations hyper intéressante mais
venez voir vous avez marvel vous avez le
musée van gogh vous avez france rugby
vous allez star wars disney pixar harry
potter dragon ball z snoopy psg la nasa
one piece bref y en a des tonnes des
tonnes des tonnes et c'est super
intéressant et puis et toutes nouvelles
qui sont arrivés rendez vous à venir les
voir qu'ils sont juste là vous allez
retrouver notamment ce monde à laurianne
si vous n'êtes pas dire si vous avez
regardé l'heure la série sur dix n'est
plus moi j'ai beaucoup aimé et gala
saison 2 qui arrive la saison 3 saison 2
je sais plus brefs les nouvelle saison
qui arrive elles sont hyper qu'annoncé
coque 2e mandat lauriane cessons les
souliers de suite vous allez également
retrouver disney classics les 101
dalmatiens la belle et le clochard on va
avoir le roi lion va avoir bambi bref
c'est sympa si vous êtes fans de disney
et bien il y en a pour toute la famille
vous avez également attaque titan way et
des coques dragon ball donc autant vous
dire que vous en avez énormément c'est
super intéressant et avec le code greu
grrr 22 vous profitez de 5% de remise
sur vos coque vos produits tous vos
accessoires son site d'origine aussi
d'aller faire un petit tour vous avez le
lien bien évidemment en bas dans la
description il nous reste donc ici dans
nos iphone de 2019 et bien le onze pros
et le 11 promax une fois de plus que je
vous conseille ici sur ses smartphones
la hausse est de venir voir du côté du
reconditionnés voulait trouver à des
tarifs intéressants et c'est bien pour
moi en ce pro à 969 euros on oublie
c'est à proscrire c'est absolument
ridicule
à ce moment là autant aller sur les
iphone 13 pour un iphone 13 à 909 euros
ça fera très très très bien la faire et
puis après qu'est ce qui se passe avec
votre iphone ils sont vraiment un peu
vieillot quand même c'est à dire que
vous avez ici les iphone de 2018 le
dissès 10 s max 10 r on peut bien
évidemment les trouver et reconditionnés
mais je vous les conseille pas alors je
vous le conseille pas si vous trouvez un
tarif vraiment pas pourquoi pas et une
fois de plus vous pourrez trouver un
tarif très bas sur dur conditionning ça
dépend de la classe mes classes à une
classe b en classe c 'est bien l'usure
du produit très usés pas usé beaucoup
puisé réparé et pourquoi pas bon voila
moi c'est des iphone qui font pour moi
trop vieillissant et qui par rapport à
ce qu'on peut retrouver aujourd'hui on
est un peu moins alors après on est fan
de 2017 c'est pareil on arrive fundis
8,8 plus alors vous me direz 250 euros
pour un iphone ça se réfléchit si on
veut de laïos pourquoi pas mais je peux
pas aujourd'hui ni repousser ces
produits ont déjà en crise on super
intéressant c'est pareil l'iphone scène
je voulais me 180 euros et sonné ok mais
bon non on va donc se dire que tous ces
produits là ce sont vraiment des
produits petit budget si on a vraiment
besoin d'un petit budget pour moi les
iphone qu'on peut encore venir voir
retrouver en reconditionnés qui sont
intéressantes avec le onze pros et le 11
promax why not mais on sait très bien
que si on vend nos efforts et ça coûte
de l'argent vous apprends rien est ce
que ça vaut le coup aujourd'hui devient
maître 300 euros sur un iphone qui sera
pas extrêmement performant en photo je
suis pas convaincu je vous conseille à
ce moment-là de venir trouver des
smartphones sur android qui seront très
performant qui font des choses pas mal
en photo à tarif équivalent en tout cas
c'est mon président donc chez moi on va
dire que tout cela est bien on leur dit
bye bye on vient travailler à partir de
l'iphone 11 promax on a donc deux gammes
une gamme 4g une gamme a5 j'ai bien
évidemment la 5g ça se paye ça coûte de
l'argent vous pouvez même venir
retrouver des smartphones à partir du 12
ans reconditionnés pourquoi pas même du
13 3 pas ça sera je vous conseille pas
des smartphones d'occasions parce que
l'occasion s'est vendu par un
particulier qu'il n'y a aucune garantie
derrière sur dur conditionné vous aurez
à minima des garanties donc
reconditionnés donc si vous intéresse
aujourd'hui est bien effectivement s'il
vous avez l'argent si vous avez les
moyens eh bien vous prenez les iphone 13
coûteront un certain budget bien
évidemment on se pose la question du
format mini c'est tout petit c'est plus
petit clou et se et l'écran est plus
grand ça c'est vachement bien pour
rajouter un peu d'argent si vous pouvez
me rajouter un petit peu vous allez sur
l'iphone 12 min vous rajoutez 200 euros
et par rapport aux et ce sera hyper
canon vous aurez exactement la même
performance mais vous aurez un écran
plus grand un smartphone plus compact
une encoche certes facile dit ok et ça
ira très très bien donc c'est bien de
2021 qui est top la gamme de 2020 qui
est encore plutôt pas mal la gale 2019
on peut y aller mais sur dur conditionné
et quelques ça donne le résultat en
photo et bien que vous ayez un iphone 12
ou un iphone 13 les photos ce sera top
ça sera vraiment top même l'iphone dont
c'était très très bon et pas qu'en photo
ou en vidéo j'avais testé à new york
j'avais été extrêmement bluffé par la
stabilisation vous avez un coup de boule
tenait la main juste comme ça vous avez
un truc est hyper stabiliser pas besoin
de prendre un grand bol on sent même pas
non c'est extrêmement stabiliser et les
photos sont très très très bonne donc
est ce qu'on retient on se pose la
question du format est ce que je veux un
gros smartphone les pros trop max très
très gros vous prenez un iphone normal
un défaut le standard et modèle pro ça
sera la même taille soit vous voulez un
smartphone tout petit pareil les tailles
d'écran est ce qu'on veut du 6,1 pouces
est ce qu'on veut du 6 à 2 7 pouces
comme du 5 24 pouces compte des 4,7
pouces ça c'est vraiment à vous de me
dire qu'est ce que vous voulez la
performance dans tous les cas ce sera au
rendez vous que ce soir-là à 15 la 14e
ou même ici de l'a13 ça marchera sans
problème vous inquiétez pas et c'est là
où apple sont balèzes c'est à dire
qu'ils sont tous maison avec très peu de
ram et sur optimist ou puisque la puce
et maison puisque le logiciel et maison
ça marche du feu de dieu c'est
incroyable la question du prix qui pour
moi le plus important est là ça va venir
vous guider un petit peu et d'autant
plus et je vous le dis une fois de plus
ses smartphones là vous pouvez les
trouver en recompte dit lyonnais je vous
ai mis tout des liens en bas dans la
description pour me retrouver aux iphone
au meilleur prix et la dernière question
à venir se poser c'est la question du
stockage parce que tous les prix que
vous indiquez ici c'est à partir d'eux
dont vous êtes trop déstockage pas à
partir de 128 giga où la plupart à
partir de 64 giga de stockage n'allait
pas entre 32 gigas est à proscrire très
clairement 64 giga sein des ponceaux
fait beaucoup de photos beaucoup de
vidéos si vous mettez beaucoup de
contenus dans votre appareil c'est pas
celui qu'il vous faudra une fois de plus
ça c'est à vous de voir par rapport à
votre budget voilà j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura aidé à dégrossir la
question pour savoir quel iphone acheté
en 2022 on sera d'autres vidéos comme ça
pour venir vous guider dans vos achats
donc si vous n'êtes pas abonné venez
vous abonner ce petit bouton et rouge
secunia toujours pas bonnes et il vous
cliquez dessus vous actionnez la cloche
comme ça vous serez notifié toc une
prochaine vidéo arrivera ça c'est
vachement bien d'ici là vous embrasse
pour le soin de vous de vos besoins et
vous beaucoup d'américains
[Musique]